[Musique]
martin biron michel david christian
dufour et daniel thibault bonsoir donné
l on va parler d'armes à feu dans une
seconde mais jouer autant de la mairesse
de montréal qui justement réclamé des
gestes plus concret de la part d'ottawa
pour tenter d'enrayer ce fléau d'armes
qui se promène entre autres à montréal
que le gouvernement fédéral entende la
demande de montréal mais pas seulement
ramené de plein d'autres grandes devises
qui doit y avoir un contrôle des armes à
feu
oui les armes d'assaut on en est heureux
que le gouvernement fédéral ait pris ses
responsabilités là dessus mais je le
demande que ce soit également pour les
armes les armes de coin a pas ce que
c'est
c'est un fléau en ce moment et ça n'a
pas de sens que ce soit uniquement la
ville de ville qui légifèrent une à la
suite de l'eau parce qu'il y ait sur les
armes se promènent bon dernière je pense
qu'elle va être déçu madame la mairesse
parce que ce qui s'en vient c'est si ça
concerne les armes d'assaut sauf erreur
et non pas les armes de poing oui voilà
à moins que à moins qu elle grâce à une
offre une surprise dans sa poche mais
pour l'instant ce que l'on sait et ce
que l'on a appris dans le courant de
l'après midi c'est que le gouvernement
va déposer la semaine prochaine ce
fameux programme de rachat d armes
d'assaut qui ont été bannis le printemps
dernier
rappelez vous il y en avait 1500 modèles
les variantes là qui ont fait l'objet de
cette première de cette première mesure
là alors le gouvernement va mettre sur
pied ce programme de rachat qui ne sera
pas obligatoire c'est une particularité
on n'avait jamais promis qui sera pas
obligatoire mais on avait un peu laissé
entendre que ce pourrait être le cas ce
qu'on va faire selon nos informations
c'est que on n'obligera pas les gens à
30 g ou échanger leurs armes contre de
l'argent
ceux qui vont décider de la garde et
devront la rendre inopérante et puis à
travers tout s'en va donner probablement
des pouvoirs supplémentaires aux
policiers pour intervenir plus
rapidement si jamais il y avait menacé
la vie
mais non violence mais bref on hilal ça
devrait être annoncé la semaine
prochaine
mais vous qui avez une grande mémoire
d'un drap l'émoicq ans avait été
annoncée en campagne électorale je me
souviens que il ya beaucoup de mères qui
avait dit à monsieur trudeau s'est pas
assez contraignant vous nous vous nous
laissez le fardeau d'obliger les gens
tout ça et on veut que l'on veut
programme plus clair et plus du oui et
on avait décidé peu après la campagne
électorale du côté du gouvernement de
scinder sens du est vraiment géré gérer
la partie armes d'assaut directement
avec bon le programme dont je vous
parlais les règles ont été établies
printemps dernier et jusqu'à nouvel
ordre la question des âmes 2.7 demeurait
un élément qui étaient dans la cour des
municipalités maintenant ce que les
événements des derniers jours pourrait
changer la donne un peu est ce que
davantage de pression je suis persuadé
que ça a suscité une discussion et pour
l'instant il n'y a pas d'indication
robot jusqu'aux hôtels très bien daniel
ce genre plaisir vous venez quand vous
voulez à ce panel merci petit mot
là-dessus peut-être martin les armes
c'est en fait c'est complexe et à chaque
fois qu'il ya des événements dont il y
en a eu à montréal récemment on rappelle
aux à tous les paliers de gouvernance
fait en plus qua non classé bat stade
aussi qui est très très sensible au
québec et c'est une bataille qui dure
depuis plus d'une trentaine d'années
depuis la tuerie de polytechnique et ça
demeure toujours difficile d'avoir avoir
un programme qui fonctionne et d'avoir
essentiellement ce qu'ils veulent ça
reste toujours très difficile de
contrôler les armes à feu au pays
oui un petit mot là dessus monsieur la
ville christian du four
oui à écouter je trouve qu'une demi
mesure la part du gouvernement fédéral
ont dit avoir acheté des armes sont
interdites
mais si vous voulez pas nous les vendre
vous pouvez les garder il ya quelque
chose d'un complet là dedans et puis de
toute manière on l'a vu la mairesse on a
vu l'intervention de la mairesse le
débat s'est déplacé l'on parle des armes
de poing
l'idée de confier sa aux villes l'écouté
la fois acheté un fusil à longueuil
passe et interdisant montréal puis vous
promener avec il ya quelque chose qui
nous a fait un compilateur ya ce qu'on
dit j'ai c'est que c'est devenu une mode
aussi dans les vidéos les armes n'a pas
de point là c'est devenu une mode d'en
posséder dans certains groupes
évidemment là christian petit mot là
dessus c'est une espèce qui est temps de
l'américaine saison croissante du canada
des excuses et une société beaucoup plus
violent que la nôtre et on a
l'impression parfois que dans les villes
en tout cas au canada
ça peut augmenter et à 10 et à dos si
délicat quand comme le dit martine même
au québec on reçoit pendant sa déco
québec le plus ce consensus peut
contrôler des hommes armés dans les
régions du québec quand même une
tradition en fait de gens qui possèdent
des armes pour qu'on va voir ce que le
gouvernement va déposer mais c'est pas
aussi quelques temps il peut s'opposer
reçu de le caricaturer les barrages
barrages ponts barrages c'est clair
qu'un un rapport il ya quelques semaines
on n'annonce pas efficace disposition
d'autres choses à faire
là il ya une pression de certaines
régions il ya une pression de
l'opposition une pression peut-être de
l'opinion publique y seraient rassurés
peut-être ou pas je fais entendre
isabelle melançon du parti libéral
pascal bérubé et la réponse très
honnêtement le des variants il y en a
aussi en abitibi on le vue ce matin il y
en a aussi à montréal il y en a dans
différentes régions
moi je pense qu'on va devoir éviter
qu'ils aient trop de circulation d'une
région à l'autre je pense que seuls ces
classes tout ce qu est impossible on ne
peut pas vivre une semaine de relâche
sans qu'il y ait aucun contrôle rappelle
jacques farré 10 nommément que les
québécois ne sont pas bienvenus en
ontario l'économie comme ça on peut
comprendre prend les responsabilités
pour sa province
mais nous est ce qu'on apprend encore
une fois on est en retard ça dort au gaz
le contrôle des allées et venues entre
les provinces et à l'intérieur de la
province font partie de nos discussions
et nos préoccupations continuer
bonjour en pots-de-vin mais martin quand
même tour de table est ce que on prépare
les gens en fonction de l'établissement
de certains barrages ça me semble
évident je sais pas si ça va être des
barrages compte elle à proprement dit
partout d'une région à l'autre mais oui
il va y avoir des consignes monsieur
legault n'a pas une énorme marge de
manoeuvre parce que le déconfinement
n'est pas si gauck sol et peut jouer
avec le couvre-feu il peut jouer avec la
surveillance du territoire
et oui peut jouer avec les barrages mais
les barrages l'hallali voix qui
s'élèvent pour obtenir des barrages
viennent surtout des régions
orange est encore dans les régions en
revanche on est assez divisés sur ce
point-là parler aux gens qui détiennent
des chalets d'hébergement touristique
ils veulent que les gens puissent entrer
avec des consignes alors le gouvernement
legault jongle avec ses positions là
pour mettre de nouvelles consignes plus
efficace mais c'est peut-être pas le
barrage à proprement dit conservation
des mesures plus strictes pouvez-vous
saguenay en abitibi dans l'est du québec
en gaspésie est celle d'un bail
il ya deux choses que ce que pour la
semaine de relâche
on devrait mettre des barrages losc
pourrait sembler justifié dans la mesure
où bon il va y avoir une grosse
circulation des gens qui on se promenait
jeu pas convaincu personne admet que
cela soit absolument nécessaire mais bon
ça pourrait se justifier pour ce qui est
du dd variant il me semble qui est un
petit peu tôt encore là pour conclure à
la nécessité des barrages
il ya une chose par contre c'est que au
début souvenez vous quand quand on avait
demandé à monsieur legault pourquoi pas
de barrages et là ils nous avaient dit
bah écoutez il a les policiers ont
d'autres choses à faire
sauvé est là a tout d'un coup a
apparemment bien il pourrait le faire
encore là la pensée de monsieur lebon
évolué et christian mais monsieur
legault se fait servir la même médecine
qu'il a servi à acheter plutôt à ce qui
est à la fermeture des frontières à
l'étranger c'est qu'ils ont mis une
pression des trois partis d'opposition
qui veulent carrément le quai des
barrages qu'on ferme les relations entre
les régions aussi faut quand même
rappeler que monsieur legault payent le
prix pour pas boire et pas avoir été
capable d'affronter cette scop puis de
la reporter carrément la semaine de
relâche
moi ce que je trouve c'est qu'on n'est
pas en phase de mesures liberticides
quand on a commencé quand on commence à
limiter les libertés le c'est plus
facile encore de le faire
quelle est la base scientifique qu'elle
élabore les bases sanitaire de ceux où
de l'eau de la page ou de l'au-delà
tannique
donc j'espère me colle au gouvernement
avant d'instaurer des barrages comme ça
va y passer comme il faut puis je suis
déçu moi je suis un de ceux qui est en
contact les trois partis d'opposition se
remettre à fonctionner je regrette
quasiment minimise la main pour tous qui
nous l'ont me rendrai que tout ce que
nous étions des surenchères ce que vous
êtes surenchère acquis la pression il ya
de la démagogie mots moi je trouve que
énormément de démagogie là et j'espère
que l'ifo allemand va être capable de
résister à moins qu'on nous prouve que
c'est nécessaire on fait pas ça si c'est
pas absolument nécessaire c'est
important les libertés manoir liverpool
je vous fais en temps gabriel
nadeau-dubois aujourd'hui qui parle de
cet endroit qui a été qui a fait l'objet
d'un rapport en disant qu'ils avaient eu
de la maltraitance pendant des années
d'une résidence privée qui reçoit des
des fonds publics
et je vous ferai entendre hier qu'on a
posé la question
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que le
patron du sus de l'époque qui était
responsable donc du traitement qu'on
faisait dans cette maison et c'est
daniel paré qui est maintenant grand
responsable des vaccins de la
vaccination
alors au nom de l'imputabilité
devrait-il payer un prix oui ou non ça
va être la question que je vous pose et
dans une seconde mais d'abord on écoute
il faut que le scandale liverpool
soir au rp à ce que le scandale et run a
été au ch à celle des privés c'est à
dire un signal d'alarmé
il faut absolument mettre fin au far
west dans le domaine des rp
que les explications du pdg vous
convainquez est-ce qu'il peut rester en
poste
compte tenu de cette information mais je
vais laisser le oui ça me préoccupe donc
je lui pose la question au ministre de
la santé monsieur paré au cours des
dernières années pendant qu'il était pdg
de chaudière appalaches a eu des codes
maltraitance puis à chaque fois il s'est
pas gêné pour fermer ou à changer les
propriétaires d'établissements il le
fait dans 13 cas comment ça se fait d co
oui si grave n'ont pas remonté jusqu'à
la haute direction du sis
comment là comment on a agi dans la
chaîne de commandement
alors daniel paré qui étaient grands
patrons doit-il qui maintenant je vous
le rappelle grand patron de la
vaccination doit-il payer un prix comme
il était le patron n'est pas partie du
tour de table messieurs
visiblement monsieur legault s'est gardé
une petite gêne pour prendre sa défense
il a envoyé la balle au ministre de la
santé ça ça veut dire qu'au gouvernement
leur tête n'est pas tout à fait fait
encore l'anglais est pas complet et on
est en train d'évaluer la situation et
des enquêtes qui sont entrés la dame
monsieur paré dit qu'ils n'étaient pas
au courant si c'est vrai il si c'est
vrai qu'il est aussi compétent on peut
penser que le système ne fonctionne pas
et que probablement y en a d'autres
comme le manoir liverpool au québec
parce que sans doute que il ya d'autres
prêts dg de 6 tout aussi compétent que
lui
alors ça c'est une inquiétude la
deuxième chose et là dessus je rejoins
le ministre la santé qui dit faut savoir
ce qui s'est passé si monsieur paris
t'es pas au courant qu'ils étaient au
courant et qui est responsable au
d'autant de maltraitance
pendant autant de temps c'est presque
criminel peut-être que la police devrait
sembler pour les gens qui n'ont pas
suivi ça peut-être c'est possible on
fait comme si tout le monde savait que
ce qui était arrivé en fait ce rapport
est accablant qui montrent la mule
malnutrition dans certains cas ya pas eu
de bain pendant de longues périodes de
temps tu donc c'est pas est reine dans
la mesure où evans et c'est le pire du
pire les gens mouraient
il tape à nourrir est abandonné c'est
pas aussi pire mais cdc des traitements
qu'on ne veut pas voir au québec en 2021
pour les personnes âgées dans une
résidence de personnes âgées michel
david
j'ai beaucoup de misère moi à croire que
monsieur paré était au courant de rien
et je vous explique pourquoi leur
enquête du ciss a été lancé à la suite
d'un reportage de radio canada qui avait
déjà mis à jour bizot jos et ses lacunes
et j'ai vérifié dans le reportage
il était bien précisé que notre collègue
l enquête avait demandé aux six de
chaudière appalaches de commenter ces
informations dans ces îles si ça veut
dire on veut pas commenter
j'imagine que la personne à qui notre
collègue s'est adressé à du référé
quelque part pour dire écoutez la radio
canada à une enquête il nous demande de
commenter qu'est-ce qu'on fait que ça
apporte monter jusqu'en haut ça m'étonne
beaucoup alors à partir de là
je comprends que de monsieur paré est
dans une opération de vaccination
délicate je pense que c'est plutôt ça
qui explique des hésitations du
gouvernement
peut-être qu'en d'autres circonstances
on ferait ce qu'on fait souvent dans des
cas comme ceux là c'est à dire qu'ils
ont le suspendre est temporairement de
ses fonctions en attendant de connaître
le fond de la faire mais que maintenant
on se dit ouah belloche changer de
pilote au milieu de la course même si la
course a ralenti lors de la course au
vaccin
alors ils supposent certains mois que la
vraie raison c'est que en quoi est ce
que c'est vraiment la version 2 de
monsieur paris d'où la réaction hier de
monsieur legault effectivement comme sur
bien martin parce qu'il ya 10 à main qui
a passé la parole à son ministre
christian duffau je suis d'accord avec
michel
ainsi monsieur paris était au courant il
y aurait dû être au courant et le
problème à mon sens c'est que on est en
face de monstres bureaucratiques ou yop
une imputabilité possible en définitive
et ça nous ramène au fait que le
problème auquel on est confronté au
québec en ce qui a trait à ses systèmes
là ça doit être réglé par une arcade du
protecteur du citoyen n'en déplaise à
monsieur legault je ne comprends pas
pourquoi monsieur legault je comprends
qu'il ya le mauvais souvenir de la com
sur charb jul qui avait duré tellement
longtemps coûté tellement cher avec des
résultats très très contestable mais
c'est pas un problème la 4l c'est un
problème de la société québécoise depuis
20-30 ans les systèmes de santé
pourquoi ça concerne le fait pour avoir
une commission dans lequel traite les
élaboré pour examiner ces modes de
fonctionnement là parce qu'il ya de plus
d'imputabilité
ce septième cet agenda entre est
quelqu'un qui est quand même
formellement responsables de liverpool
j'avais parlé des roms
ça me fait penser et ron carmel ce gala
est au coeur de la campagne de
vaccination ça marche pas mais parce que
c'est tout la même gamme série de
fonctionnaires en troubles qui se nomme
qu'il dans quelque chose qui marche
moi je ne critique jamais les
infirmières et préposés aux
bénéficiaires les gens qui sont sur le
terrain mais toute cette infrastructure
bureaucratique là ça marche pas c'est ça
le problème c'est pas la protectrice
mais qui va arriver très bien c'est bien
compris
christian là je voulais c'est une
maîtrise reste trois minutes passaient
pas la garde du sien qui sait pas mais
je vais faire votre votre avis sur ce
qu'a fait le chef du parti québécois
dont les coudes c'est un anglais c'est
la fin d'une conférence de presse
aujourd'hui où il se posait des
questions sur monsieur legault d'elle la
bulle familiale pas de bulle familiale
en école de françois legault du ring
snowboard
aie aie un tweet après de paul st pierre
plamondon pour revenir sur mon
affirmation se battant pour une presse
nous disposions nous disposions d'autres
infos nous indiquant que les deux fils
du pm n'habitait pas chez lui mais sur
le goût confirme que ces enfants vivent
à son domicile dans quel but je croit
ses paroles et retire mes propos
rapidement il reste pas beaucoup de
temps martin bayonne règle non écrite je
pensais québec qui est on ne touche pas
aux enfants ni aux conjoints des
politiciens à moins d'avoir des preuves
béton et monsieur st pierre plamondon
s'est brûlé les doigts et je vous dirais
que le bruit courait depuis la semaine
dernière dans le caucus péquiste que les
enfants monsieur legault n'habitait pas
avec lui
est-ce qu'il s'est fait prendre par les
ouï-dire de son caucus à cause peut-être
de son inexpérience mais il s'est
vraiment fait prendre dans la trappe
michel david ben je me souviens d'avoir
entendu monsieur legault ou prétend dire
qu'il s'ennuyait de sega pass
qu'habitait pas avec lui
alors je sais peut-être sur cette
impression au loc
monsieur saint père le monde ont lancé
sa charge
maintenant la situation a changé
monsieur legault et à québec à ce
moment-là de ces schistes et tech
présume à montréal et monsieur on aurait
dû faire la vérification et je trouve
que monsieur saint pierre de l'abandon
tire un peu vite dans toutes les
élections je comprends qu'il veut de la
visibilité parce que sa situation fait
qu'il y en a pas beaucoup mais
cette acquisition doit être vérifiée
avant de lancer sa place par christian
il reste un sérieux the do bumba que le
contexte actuel avait même déjà comme
très saint père à mort dont certaines
passent à faire des choses un peu plus
basse que dangereux de ce fait attaquer
du helmand les gens quand on se laisse
là dessus merci beaucoup au revoir bonne
soirée à bien tous leurs avoirs pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit